League of Legends is a team-based game
riot has made a very sure of that
through tweaking the game and balancing
it in such a way that you need five
players playing together as a team to
win the game but over the course of the
game is history one lane has always been
at the center of League of Legends
explosive growth it's the one in the
center the mid line that's not to say
that mid is the most important position
increased like I said riot has bounced
in such a way that they're all equally
important but somehow the growth of mid
has always tied directly into the growth
of League of Legends have you ever
wondered why so many teams have
superstar mid laners why the players
often credited with pushing the game
forward
historically play dammit it's because
mid has so often been the place where
the best of the best pop off
hey before we get into it if you want a
sweetness for eSports branded shirt just
like this or any of our other pieces of
merch you can check out our store you'll
find a link in the comments below
I think pinky's had something to prove
against everybody pick is a player that
always shows up when the pressure hits
he is probably the most popular European
player and has been for a very long time
clock : good they were all totally okay
to connect cool orator Cicero Tudor I
saw a tall nearly due to my palette or
bottom as I see okay I've seen you much
so here's a fun fact if you didn't start
watching League of Legends until 2015
like me you probably didn't know that in
the earliest days of the game there
wasn't really a mid-laner person in the
earliest days of the game preseason 1
even there were differing opinions on
what kind of champions should be played
in which and as well for horses but uh
this is really gonna be a farm lane for
now before it's getting a little bit
unsafe takes about 112 damage now on her
and hits another wild card so this one's
it's getting harassed super hard by TF
and she's actually miss playing this
lane because of that prevailing opinion
early on was a team should send their
range ad carry the characters needed the
most farm the middle name which was the
shortest late and that's the easiest to
get farming just like in dota of course
they didn't realize that mid is also the
most bankable land Lee thanks for the
bushes on either side so the ad carry
was sent bought to be babysat by support
who keeps them alive while they farmed
there was also a growing understanding
of macro in the League of Legends team
as people got to understand the game
they realized that the mid outer turret
was extremely important since it unlocks
both sides of your opponent's jungle
unlike the one side offered by the
sidelines right here
just on a dip dye but yes that's hurt is
gone now set is 1 & 2 turret kills for
epic but only 1 kill for CLG and maybe
they're gonna pick up more key objective
staying alive and defending mid started
to become incredibly important and so
we've started seeing major yeoman most
majors offered either mobility or crowd
control to help escape ganks and burst
damage to help them capitalize on ganks
themselves by the time season one world
rolled around we pretty much had the
standard Elaine set up with a tank or
bruiser top mage mid 80 carrying support
fought and a jungler in between taking a
lot of tarnish off let me sell in
dodging thankfully those slows will not
does Oh blowed up right there wow that
damage upper was stronger than his own
in Europe which eventually became known
for pumping out some of the best mid
laners in the world
we had froggen Alex each Ocelot and
x-pac at an na TSM always played around
Reginald and it season two worlds the
Taipei assassins took first place thanks
in part to toys and it's incredible
Oriana play straight down before you had
a chance to react so that was he gets a
second so gonna get justice both ghosts
you can lock them down with the turrets
damn he gets out of that and it's just
huge pressure from taipei assassins
right now he it's now three two three
four two three now finally the last Auto
Attack and double kill for toys da
signed up my own beeswax away shock
Mikey's like that double bowl let's give
it a go
beautiful beautiful play by Joy sets a
single hot seat take down clouds up up
but by season three there was a [ __ ] in
the kind of Champions we saw play to
mid-majors were already popular but
assassins began to take over the metal
assassins were the source of some of the
flashiest those incredible plays in
season 3 and their strength in the
middle a man that you knew that strong
mechanically talented mid laner to take
advantage of their power
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
that change was happening at the same
time that League of Legends was
undergoing explosive growth leagues were
popping up all over the world with the
na and EU LCS in the West and the LPL in
China both OGN champions continued to
showcase high level gameplay from Korea
and of course fans got to see incredible
mid laners tearing it off on a high-risk
high-reward of mechanical champions like
Ahri eventually waiting back I think try
to bait that one but it may well turn
back around on it from 2013 to 2014
assassins ruled the League of Legends
meta sure there were other viable picks
but the best players were playing
assassins and styling on their opponents
which meant that some of the very best
team in the world were playing around a
skillful mid laner
gameplay wise is very strong we also
invest shout :
he also plays a lot of champions and
it's very aggressive in lane similar to
register mid lane is definitely about
having a lot of pressure which is also
wild all the teams choose to gank mid a
lot usually they'll ask for ganks a lot
I have to do it or else they take my
race you definitely need to have a good
relationship with your jungler I'm
basically I start doing everything he
wants it also meant that the very best
mid leaders in the world we're pushing
the limit of what people thought was
possible in the game which is tricky
force that is fertilizer it's all about
firefights
Bart going down what is he going to be
enough Sun it is gonna be just to get a
quick and they kill survive what a pure
out play from pecking we have to see
that one again in slow-mo they were in
advancing the meta with incredible play
which made them into some of the game's
most famous players also check out and
I'm gonna to do something wrong to get a
run in the manual aho or could only
Nestle bunny I'm good with a wind a
penalty
[Music]
guys like bjergsen that's the deathlok
of the Krantz or business gonna try and
get any finishes he picks up a double
kill for a little in it's a triple kill
Aaron a is gonna get take that view to
get the quarter da de da de coming in
the solo player so served on a that I
can see open at all he doesn't I know he
does kill him and now da Dave I'm
fighting with Marta he's gonna get
another one too cute and Baker
[ __ ] what Baker just execute so
efficient in that mid lane as the years
have gone on though the mid lane has
gotten a little less flashy assassins
are still playable but like any role
their power fluctuates depending on the
medic MIT has settled down and just says
the meta changes you can't really do
that as well because champions go away
they're just not champions that we're as
viable anymore backline may just become
important like Orianna waveclear ones
that are necessary my forte so it's just
like the meta started shifting away from
me on top of not me after the injury and
it's kind of like snowball into like
something it's still an important spot
on the map given that the whole game
literally revolves around the mid lane
but it's not the place where everything
happened the way it was just a few years
ago even so we're still seeing a new era
of exciting medellin talent among i've
already made the statement before I said
I think he's a he faces the most
mechanically gifted player we have ever
sent out of Europe he can do everything
in game when it comes to executing any
kind of jammed in any kind of matchup
any kind of setup not all teams are
exclusively playing around men but when
it came time for g2 to rebuild our
roster they only kept their star mid
laner parks and built the team around
the him defensive musi teleports coming
down
stop RNG watch from that now way ahead
of salary being a favorite in this
tournament if you get more chow who make
it so a wild no way is ticking down 100
bucks gets the solo kill
this is his teeth your other top team
has often played around there Stallworth
ad carry's reckless but they embrace
leasing success when they play around
their young rising star in the middle
over in China and victus gaming the mid
laner rookie has been a powerhouse for
much of his career but this year he's
come into his own as the de facto
strongest mid laner in the world now in
trouble did have to flash away the
ignite burning dies I could not believe
rocky ate that
well kt rolster 17 year old rookie
mutant town help the team earn a 1st
place play-off finish for the first time
since the summer of 2014 a new era of
the mid lane is done and hopefully and
that new talent growth League of Legends
can grow along with them this is all
about the Miss Lane matchup with so many
crazy things going on to the meta you
could look in any direction you want but
for me it's all about caps the perks
these guys are incredible performance
they're two of the strongest mid laners
in the earthly hell's Jeff
we just want to prove ourselves I feel
like us been not performing too good at
worlds for a while now and we want to
change that so this is our world
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]